clocks
[Music]
all right guys you guys are obviously
used to how we do things over here at
sng yeah yeah and uh for now we are
about to start with the question of the
week and the question of the week is
most evil thing someone has said to you
during an argument oh I know this was
was vicious yeah well it was vicious a
lot of them were very repetitive a lot
of them was like oh you wish you weren't
born and blah all these boring stuff
your mom this your dad yeah you know the
typical stuff you're saying like Primary
School all right but um um just before
you start hit me I want to apologize to
everyone for my mood last week I just
want to put it out there I really want
to apologize for my mood last week I was
going off like an hour of sleep
um I wasn't putting two and two together
okay I wasn't in the right head space I
took our you I took out on REM I took it
out on the question that you asked the
fans uh and that wasn't fair oh the
festival thing yeah yeah yeah that
[__] festival thing I was angry yeah
and I took out on everyone except for
Ellis
um so this week I'm gonna do the
opposite I'm only gonna take out another
list
I'm playing [__] a lot um but right yes
I'm in a much better mood I've slept
more and I'm feeling juicy cool
most evil things someone has said to you
during an argument
I don't want kids with you because your
brother has cancer
Pro
what Justice in the jeans
bro
damn man damn indeed damn indeed all
right that's what I went start off you
give off big energy but it's just so
disappointing
host uh
yeah yeah I'd pick her up I pick her up
from her yeah from a cranial ah
oh it's just so disappointing just so
disappointing
now I see why you are bullied for most
of your life
that was if you're if you were bullied
and you slowly like worked your way back
up to like a place where self-respect
self-respect yeah self-love yeah that's
gonna send you straight back straight
back to the pits yeah yeah wow now I see
why you're bullied from yeah that will
trigger me I say why bully me then oh
now
[Music]
I'm in the streets now wow oh God
I torn my ex that her best friend gives
head better than her
oh okay that's that's crazy that's a
great way that is bravado and that is a
Death Wish yeah that is can't be doing
stuff like that man your best friend
gets better head than you that's kind of
stuff will send a woman crazy
you can't sleep that night you can't
sleep down 100 you better send that via
text of course and you better be abroad
of course God forbid they've made up
because she's coming for her that night
the bridge
oh God yeah God forbid indeed Jesus
Christ I never have the balls to say
that something you just can't you just
even if I really really really wanted to
yeah yeah never have the balls yeah
that's a that's a take next one I hope
all of your life's Joys disappear
damn
that's why your hairline starts behind
your ears
that's crazy
that's far back that's when that's the
you think yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah from the office the
um Kevin Toby nah the pat have you
spoken with Pac-Man oh yeah yeah yeah
it's not that's a perfect toupee top
yeah it is it is they glue that [__]
yeah yeah he looks pristine again yeah
right
I can give you the number to all of my
hoes and they'll tell you that you get
the best treatment
that's a double entender it is yeah
that's a that's a compliment and a mini
mean at the same time yeah wow
my uh my boyfriend said he if you don't
get me off tonight I swear I'll be
someone else in the morning
I swear that the swear is what takes a
cake I swear I'll find someone in the
morning
what if you don't get me off tonight
that's a threat right that's the
definition of a threat if you don't get
me off wow and she wouldn't know what to
do yeah because she doesn't want to lose
him
she can't be treated like that she can't
be so she doesn't want to get him off
she can't be treated like that bro God
my uh the gym is literally a 15 minute
walk from here if your heart can't
handle that level of intensity I don't
think it can handle this relationship
[__] yeah
it's the heart can't handle this level
of intensity
that's a that's a secret fact wow I'm
not trying to Fat shame anyone but yeah
wow
yeah yeah
your mother should have let that lady
kidnap you
you good Ellis yeah yeah you sure
Jesus
good no because that was sent the fear
coming straight back to that moment yeah
yeah I remember losing my mum in that
Debenhams when I was a you swear
I was crying oh no them turn around yeah
Mom and you don't want to shout yeah Mom
Mom
gone the fear that runs through your
veins
on my ones I mean was your brother with
your mum yeah that's what I meant yeah
my brother was with my mom oh they were
gone what were you doing bro were you
like do you see Simon I was probably
just playing I used to me and my brother
used to play hadn't seeking the clothes
bro
sorry we used to play hard to see in the
clothes yeah so I probably just I
probably stayed in there too long
seeking yeah yeah
they can't find me peeked out oh God oh
I cried what he resolved it my mom found
me
yeah you know Australia as well because
it's like
you hear that James James and you're
like thank God Ryan to my mom
don't you
ever you're ever mom you're all so
scared
[Laughter]
I should have stayed I should have
stayed hitting there you should have
kidnapped me yeah yeah they should have
kidnapped me because I wouldn't be
getting treated like yeah I'll be
getting sweets
I've been getting sweets in exchange for
socks
yeah I'm just getting Toms
too far too far too far too far too far
too far too far yeah
oh God I'm back to it
most evil thing someone has said to you
during an argument my boyfriend called
me a painted on eyebrow
[Laughter]
wow
that sea bomb is what really kicked it
off it did it did the streets don't like
that word wow I painted on
it's like broken English again
slow down you read it it is
a tongue twister oh God ah
you look like God Made You with his eyes
closed I think about it often and repent
Peak damn Peak my ex dumped me I cried
and told him how much I loved him his
exact words were you're so pathetic
it's tough
crying begging you're so pathetic that's
insane
spoiler alert I'm gonna try I'm not
gonna give any names okay top boy yeah
there's a bit in there or someone [__]
about okay they come to their senses and
they beg someone else for forgiveness
okay and say if I fix it can you give me
a pass mine said [__] your past they
said all right bet please if you're not
gonna give me a pass I'm begging you
do not hurt my family I know what you're
gonna do to me yeah just don't hurt my
family yeah yeah man said stop begging
it's pathetic no he said it's disgusting
he said don't beg bro it's disgusting
that's when you know these are like real
road yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah don't beg because I gave you an
opportunity and you [__] up yeah yeah
you [__] it so deal with a concert
deal with the consequences bro and
they're like bro please please please
please please please it's calm I get it
you're gonna murder me yeah I've charged
my life from here but the fam please
please I'm begging you leave them alone
Manchester men didn't even entertain the
question yeah I just said don't beg it's
disgusting that whole the fear I promise
you I would have to take his life there
and then because you're saying I'm X
yeah and you say my fam is X yeah and
you're saying I'm disgusted yeah
Tipping Point yeah yeah I've got nothing
left to lose and you've left me with no
dignity facts you have to take his life
just take him out then
say that's crazy that is crazy but the
repercussions are long for him though if
he does take him out then I don't
obviously I don't know the scenario
because I'm not seeing it yet but if he
does take his left then there's Peak
facts but yeah uh I've got a few left
um most evil thing right
you should be you should be running on
the treadmill instead of running your
mouth oh Jesus mad all right you have to
say this one to me right all right say
to me I know you're cheating on me in
character all right
I feel that I know you're cheating on me
and
[Applause]
there's nothing I can say there is
nothing and it hurts my feelings and and
what are you gonna do about it
I don't care I'm fix our room I can
all about the drama sometimes this is
the reason why you can't lose weight
you're too full of [__]
that's that's intelligent that isn't it
yeah wow yeah I wouldn't know what to
say because I know I'm dealing with a
pro yeah yeah he's been doing this yeah
yeah yeah band doing this so I can't
lose weight you're full of [__]
because it seems like you've been
waiting to say that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
damn [__] [__] indeed there's no
difference between you and them New York
rats
damn Jesus dancing up big as well
I've been cheating on you for the past
five months she's pregnant and she's
keeping it
he's uh that's not even him trying to be
mean yeah it's just a case of I I charge
it and I have to be caught yeah yeah I'm
not dealing I don't have time yeah to to
take your feelings into consideration
I've lost everything everything so I'm
just telling you the facts one by one by
one yeah and then I'm gonna leave thanks
yeah that's not what you will the thing
is with me yeah this is why I'm not a
completed human being a completed
completed like I'm not
like
I'm just not mature enough there's
certain tendencies in my personality
that I know I'm not mature enough and I
have a Tipping Point for everything an
emotional Tipping Point okay where I can
like be composed
empathetic take people's feelings into
consideration and delicate that's a
scenario
where even the love of my life I can't
take your feelings into consideration
because it's like
my life
isn't Smithereens yeah I've lost you
I've lost this this house I've lost this
life and I'll have to deal with this
[__] and her kid
your kid yeah
I don't have it in me to be like grovely
and apologetic and all that kind of
stuff I have to just run up in there
like
babe it is what it is I'm a dog I did
some dog [__] I'm Gonna Leave bro
because you can't take me back yeah
exactly take me back because while this
is going on
if you think I'm apologizing for the the
rest of this thing
I'll take my life
I'm gonna end me bro I'm gonna end me
I'm gonna end me to do with her to I
can't afford whatever what was coming in
the next six months what could you say
you would do I get my life
[Laughter]
this is not funny guys it's just the
worst spot yeah
[Laughter]
[__] bro yeah I can't entertain
something oh facts bro I literally
there's the same thing when I said about
like when these Lots meet up when the
side chick meets up with the wife and
then they pincer you together yeah yeah
it's like yeah yeah yeah I I don't have
time I don't I have the time I don't
have the emotional maturity to take care
of both of you in this situation
over it I'm sorry but I'm dead behind
the eyes at that point yeah [__] fair
enough my soul shadows and I'll just
move on yeah yeah yeah fair fair makes
sense all right I've got two more yeah
yeah okay most people think uh someone
has said to you something someone has
said to you during an argument
nobody wants you but me and if they do
it's because of what you've got going
for yourself
because it makes any sense
I'm assuming he's just saying tits
probably I have something physical yes
or probably like it's external you're I
doubt he's talking about her master's
degree yeah it's like pretty privileged
or something yeah yeah certainly you're
going for it you just cheeked up yeah
that's it no one else wants you though
nobody else wants it
oh this might be the worst one this is
the last one as well
your sister never gives me these
problems
craziest chat for that to be the reveal
that's
you'd freeze your sister never gives me
these problems if I receive that I don't
know who I'm slicing first
you know what I'm saying bro I don't
know who I'm slicing first imagine your
love saying James doesn't chat this much
[__]
I he just [__] me and moves on
I can't entertain this conversation I
actually can't entertain that
conversation because I'm there he blows
my back out pay some bills and dips like
a man
James doesn't give me these problems I
can't hear the love of my life saver
I couldn't
wow I couldn't because everything's
charged yeah of course a lot of mouths
are not going to be fed anymore yeah bro
wow you man would have you man would
better start looking for jobs yeah
that's what I'm saying indeed indeed
yeah wow bro yeah that was the last one
Jesus Christ and I also couldn't get a
text from her and then a call from you
immediately
I couldn't see like my phone go ding
yeah and just see Foo has Ting and then
your name popped up immediate after
I love my phone that's another thing
while I'm dead behind the eyes I don't
have time for your emotion High emotion
my Innovation I've lost everything every
single thing bro
damn anyway welcome back guys we've been
too surpark on so many words recently
Jesus
um what did we say in Manchester I can't
remember we said you ran over and
spotted me Fam we said a whole sentence
at the same time
um
and you said you both said um you just
charged it until the next one I think
yeah
word four words exact same time crazy it
was crazy
um God that dressing room was hot
yeah anyway guys welcome back happy
Monday fun day
um we love you as always if you came to
see us on tour the last couple weeks
again thank you yes sir um it's been a
trip man it has been a trip uh the Log
Cabin tour is officially over and we're
we're on to bigger and better things
moving forward and we can't wait to
share the information with you so if you
want to hear about the new things first
head on over to patreon.com forward
slash chicks and gigs okay indoctrinate
yourself into our little thing that
we've got going on our little Ting
that's not so little because we're
booked and busy and the daddies take
care of you we do we take care of you so
head on over right now digest all the
content that we've put on over there
all of the content that we put on there
over the last few years binge away get
the updates get the discounts
join the Discord [__] chirp setting
[__] three pound a month 10p a day run
the P to S and G come on dog okay in the
meantime guys if you are listening to us
on any audio platform please leave us a
nice review five stars is preferable but
whatever you say say it with your
goddamn chess and guys if you are
watching us on YouTube please subscribe
to the channel and without any further
Ado we have the game of the day it's
time for time
let's go guys everyone grab your board
grab your markers if you're playing at
home get ready steady what's the scores
12 7 3 at the moment 12 7 3 yeah okay
it's gonna be five episodes to break
even steamrolling ahead bro
steam rolling ahead we're gonna need a
new game at this point the top five this
week is the countries with the highest
number of McDonald's restaurants oh my
God okay that's a cool one that's very
cool I like that that's anyone's game
that's very cool when you say couldn't
use a lot of [__] but McDonald's is fun
countries with the highest number of
McDonald's restaurants
first things what came to my head yeah
I'm locked room locked oh we're all
locked yeah yeah let's go cool uh Ellis
since you were first and quick with it
um pause
top five please cool so gone for Japan
India
USA UK and Australia
nice bro
I've gone for USA Canada Australia China
Russia
Russia China that's what I'm Jimmy
USA UK Japan I've got France
and Canada
number 10.
Philippines okay cool
number nine
which only two of you wrote
Australia
[__]
number eight
Brazil
I was thinking Brazil I was close
I think in Brazil number seven
UK oh [__] oh God
loads in the UK number six
Canada [__] oh my God Oh my days number
five
Germany
nobody wrote Germany I was France and
Germany I was tossing
pause pause what
from Germany I was talking just
number four
France
[Laughter]
number three
Japan come on okay nice number two
China no way
oh
I didn't know the Communist man then
would have it like that I'm not gonna
lie to you
and number one obviously USA one has to
be USA yeah so it's twos is it nah I've
got three Jimmy one oh he's got three so
three two
two
fun fact
Russia has no McDonald's you know it was
a it was a stab in a dark because
obviously that's what said these
Communists
it was yeah I should have I should have
deeped it I did take it into
consideration but I still went with it
anyway
two other countries that don't have
McDonald's can you guess
um countries that don't have McDonald's
Mexico North Korea Mexico definitely has
them nope oh North Korea maybe but it's
not on this list all right uh two other
countries that don't have McDonald's
[Music]
Iceland
well [__] played yes Iceland let's go
I knew it'd be Iceland it's so isolated
it's so isolated then we've got [__] all
fair in Russia in the best way Iceland
and there's one more according to this
list
[__] Ukraine no Kazakhstan
Fair yeah no one was getting that but
fair place is that a part of Russia
right
is it maybe I think maybe actually I
think so now you say that let's go
inside a flag so uh I don't know anyway
be wrong that's what I'm saying so I
don't think so it's own country but as
in just like Ukraine used to be part of
Russia yeah
yeah yeah they're neighbors it's Russia
adjacent yeah
is what 13 13. I need to think of new
games because this is [__]
he's giving up on the squads it's
[__] I saw this bro well played all
right gang thank you for that G I needed
that dub right guys let's take a very
quick break to pay some bills fellas
listen up are you running into some
stubble trouble are you dreaming of that
clean shaven look I hate going through
the hassle of a wet shave every other
day facts I know you are that's why we
have partnered with manscaped the brand
for below the waist is coming to save
that beautiful face
yes sir
so manscape now has beard products and
is going a step further with the launch
of their brand new handyman electric
face shaver it's designed to give your
face that smooth and chiseled finish
without the mess of a traditional shave
make sure to join the 9 million men
worldwide who trust manscaped with our
exclusive offer head over to
manscape.com and use the code sng zero
November gold 20 off plus free shipping
let's get back to the Juicy Juice right
so you've got dilemma for us I do I'm a
38 year old divorced mum and I have a 30
year old 13 year old son who I
successfully uh co-parent with my
ex-husband no drama
my ex and I have always had different
views on certain aspects of parenting
I'm African he's Aussie so you can
imagine the polarity
anyway I'm used to the word polarity
um
anyway my son is five foot eleven
captain of the rugby team and can be
quite charming and hilarious when he
wants to
these are all good things however I
started to notice that when he was 11
that he started to get a lot of
attention from females including much
older females I mean actual women when
he was 11
it is disgusting don't get me wrong for
example
for example
when he comes by my office I'd get a lot
of girls in their 20s comment commenting
on his disarming on his disarming looks
and say they're putting him on
they're putting him on on what Bay Lake
I don't know what that means on Bay
layby
oh on like Bay layaway almost oh I'm
assuming that's what she's trying to say
yeah like benching in for Bay okay okay
okay
cool he's next up
now this all seems harmless but it does
ring it does raise alarm Bells
especially being in Asia where I where
this kind of thing is fetishized
um well like black people being
feticized I've experienced this myself
I've always been scared he'll get taken
advantage of by older women
now recently my son told me he had a
girlfriend he has a girlfriend who is
two years older than him she's going
she's 15 going on 16. on one hand I love
that my kid can freely have these kind
of conversations with me but on the
other hand I don't know how I feel about
these older girls
um this about this older girlfriend
situation at his age he's 13 for
Christ's sake I'm worried that because
she's older than him she's going to
teach him stuff
she's going to teach him stuff he's
going to teach him stuff bro how about
she's 16. she's going on 16. yeah 20
some staff
despite having talked to him several
times about sex and wait until he's old
enough to Bear the responsibilities that
come with it I also know that teenage
boys have one thing on their mind and
don't really give a [__] what their
parents say
facts I've made my expectations be known
to him but I have no control what he
does at his dad's place
his dad is the up his dad is of the
opinion that it's going to happen so it
might as well happen at home excuse me
hell no I will do whatever it takes to
slow the trajectory of this kid having
sex the African parent in me is
panicking and wants to nip this this
little relationship in the bud ASAP but
I also but I am also careful not to
alienate my son to a point where he
stops telling me stuff and starts
sneaking around behind our backs help
what do I do knowing what you um well
like as young boys are you grateful to
have have had a no-nonsense parents or
would you have rather they been less
strict what would you do with your own
kids at the I'm tolerating his little
relationship stage but deep down my
ancestors are uncertain in a whisper in
my ear what kind of new age nonsense is
this
PS if I don't hear back in four weeks
I'm going with the ancestors
so
recap
uh 30 year old divorced woman 13 year
old son co-parent with her ex-partner
she's African he's Aussie sun is five
foot eleven captain of rugby team
Charming wedge pause
um Galley all over him in school Gary
all over him at his mom's work
now a few years down the line he's got a
girl older than him she's 16 and she's
afraid he's she's gonna teach him stuff
pops is down for it if anything if it
happens it's gonna happen at yard she's
like hell [__] no and I'm gonna do
everything I can as an African parent to
slow this [__] doubt
thoughts long story short
honest opinion
[Music]
if I was 13
and I've just patented a 16 year old
body there
is not a power on this Earth
that will stop me from banging distance
there's not a Bible passage
or no ancestors I'm banging this girl
there is nothing on this planet that
will stop me at 13. yeah and I'm draws
in a 16 year old are you crazy I plus do
you think for a second I will be allowed
back on the playground if I have to tell
the mandam I couldn't clap it because my
mum shut down the dance
wow perspective
I bought a 16 year old body back because
my mom shot down perspective nah bro
I'll never recover parents will never
understand that side of a kid's life
fact ever facts obviously they might
remember it or they might Loosely
remember it at their age but you're just
never gonna remember when it's your
child and yeah of course going back to
like you're right bro going back to the
playground or the mandem or your form
class and say you bottled it it's the
worst thing you can do and you better
not lie about it bro wow and plus she's
older but she's still in your school
[__] so she's telling everyone so you're
ruined from top to bottom
yeah I try to suck him off and his mom
ran in and shy down
she said I'm going with the ancestors on
this one yo yeah you can't recover
personally
it's hard to it's hard to give advice to
you because I don't feel like you can un
fully understand the ramifications of
what you're going to put your son
through yeah because
I feel like that's the reason why the
pops are saying if it's gonna happen let
it happen under my roof because one he's
a man he understands like male sexual
nature especially as a young growing
teen but within the same breath
I understand your logic about wanting to
not have this happen at [__] what 13
years
that's scary yeah it's scary on and the
thing is at 13 you think you you could
you could tackle [__] if it was
presented I couldn't tackle it when I
was 16. oh God
yeah I couldn't tackle it then facts so
13 I would have bowled it the best thing
the best advice I would say is chat to
Pops and be like
you need to put the fear of God in him
and let him know
brother I know you're cast but I promise
you when she puts it down on you you're
gonna [__] yourself yeah yeah yeah take
it as slow as you possibly can get
comfortable lips in her get comfortable
dry humping her get a comfortable
thinker and uh get comfortable with
these hand jobs yeah put it all off as
long as you possibly can before you bang
this girl because I promise you you're
going to [__] the bed yeah and we can't
let that happen you can't and he will
under the kid hopefully the kid
understands and be like Fair because if
you do he just needs to reinstill that
fear of if you do [__] the bed the
school's gonna fight yeah everyone's
gonna find out he's gonna find out he's
gonna be [__] so then he might double
down and be like if I do [__] if I don't
[__] everyone's gonna find out so you
might as well just bang her you know
what I mean at least because even if one
example I [__] the bed and I didn't bang
her the other example is at least I got
[__]
might as well Banger and take the Brunt
bomb 13. bro if I was yeah if I was a
dad I would say bro I'm gassed for you
but [__] this is a lot to handle let me
coach you through this as best as I can
um and trust me
keep the lines of communication open and
we'll make sure you bang this girl but
please don't rush this I just realized
don't bang her don't back bro 13. I just
deep thought underage that is is oh oh
okay obviously it's underage and I'm not
condoning this pedophilia
but same same I was 13. yeah I want to
tell you when I was 13 Madam I was ready
I wasn't ready ready but my dick was
ready ready wow I was [__] at 13.
yeah no stop yeah eight for eggs
wow so I would there was no there was no
reality where a year 10 slash year 11
Ting was putting it on man five eleven
he's in here yeah I'm just deep because
when she was going about five eleven I
was like big whoop 13. yeah he's a man
he goes to the mom's office and 20 year
old like raw hold him for me he's 13.
that's that's too much power Gary
that's too much power to deal with
he caught he can't wait to turn 18. he
can't wait to turn 18. he doesn't know
where he's gonna make him swallow spit
because I can't even imagine it yeah
he's listening too much power for a
young man darling take the innocent
child you've got for now because when
he's of age yeah it's game over his game
yeah be preparing or not he's not gonna
matter be prepared to have grandkids
that's all you need yeah he's gonna be
used to average pum by the time he's 16.
facts and he's so the daddy is going to
be collecting at 18 he can't pull out he
can't he won't yeah anyway yeah they're
all fast because they want his jeans
from early
because they know they're not getting
better than this so
all I would say
is express your concerns to him hmm
but the more you add pressure on
shutting this [__] down he's going to do
it yeah he's gonna get it and he's going
to rush through it fast he's gonna
figure this is a ticking Time Bomb I
have to find this girl now because my
mom is Ops facts so I would yeah
personally like I said before chat to
the dad explain your concerns and be
like I know your gas for him but
you must know what you must remember was
that to be 13. he can't handle this and
if he [__] this up the whole school is
gonna be the last of the whole school
he's got a great opportunity don't [__]
it up and the dad might be like
because yeah there's no way I can handle
this a year right there's just no way I
can handle this in your way so much
wow that's too much yeah yeah yeah yeah
it'll be the best situation I could
possibly possibly imagine I mean would
it be the best though because in your
eight and I'm back in the year 10 11.
there's all good
being the buffest guy in the school or
whatever buff is going your year at year
eight and older things want to bang you
buff I get that I get that but when it
actually comes down to the ads because
you need to understand he will be gassed
in school surrounded by his boys other
people blah blah that's that guy that's
that guy yeah yeah yeah yeah when it
actually comes to the one-on-one
situation with the gal he's gonna be a
nervous wreck because he's never done
this of course so
it's a double-edged sword kind of thing
I mean it is but like
you got to get you're he's gonna be
Shook at 13 14 15 16 so shock your shook
his shot yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Chucky
shook so bro like he might as well not
it's not he's not it's not he might as
well get it done now but he's in the
situation now she's gone on one at bang
he's gonna be desperate to bang so who
are we kidding here it's a ham yeah
that's crazy who are we kidding yeah
yeah yeah yeah eight bro that's crazy
that was the prime of my holiness
I think mine was like
uh
uh yeah eight year nine was definitely
yeah I would say I would say you're nine
because I think you get eight yeah eight
it was my first girlfriend and my first
lips
I've never been so scared oh Fair yeah
yeah yeah you've never been so sorry I
was terrified for my first lips mine was
in year eight as well my first lips I
remember I think I've definitely said on
there before
my sister had a man at the time I mean
obviously yeah I was in boarder school
um she was in the same school as well it
was like like her I don't know what what
they called it but there was a time
before dinner I think either before
dinner or after dinner we had like an
hour's play everyone was just [__] about
yeah yeah so that the boys and girls
were mixing like the the play a
playground per se
um and my sister was with her boy at the
time and they had known that me and my
girl at the time had never lips
all right you two lips now so they were
stood up first of all I'm not watching
my sister lips I was first of all I was
yeah I didn't know them things then I
didn't know what that was then I was
like yeah yeah yeah I needed guide my
sister's all I had yeah
uh so they lips they were standing up
and me and my girl at the time were
sitting down I remember their lips were
racing James he said all right you two
lips I looked at her I looked away oh I
looked at her and looked away I was like
oh my God oh my God oh my God I was
thinking oh my God oh my God
and they were like I bet they said the
worst thing we'll count you down no you
man no every second no no no I would
have been terrified bro my heart was
beaten it got to one looked her pecked
and locked away yeah it was a pet it
wasn't a French it was a peck oh it's
red I don't think I frenched her for
months damn bro yeah we were doing
little Peck Peck things Here There and
Everywhere but then I think year nine is
when I Blossom because obviously after
yeah eight was training wheels yeah yeah
nine the wheels came off yeah it's a lot
yeah yeah yeah it was a lot that's what
I'm saying sexing it hey James that's
crazy oh I think mate hang on that's
what I'm saying bro I'm pretty sure my
sister's in your eight
[__] conversation
now [__] this
she's a child
I've just taped it she's a [__] child
nah bro nah I'm over it I'm over he's
not banging anyone
wrong
that's too funny Jesus it's just made
sense bam bro I'm telling you she's a
child for that
oh my God oh my God the fear of God in
it
it was this young damn
my year right perspective through my own
eyes yeah I thought
facts bro Jesus she's a child yeah yeah
it compounds yeah moving on lock that
whole [__] down forget everything I said
[__] lock it down have to lock it down
bro good Lord It's Too Young it's too
young it's crazy way too young okay cool
right I've got a thread so this one
we've done before
[Music]
um maybe even twice but the internet's
recently re-upped it okay so I'm
re-upping it cool so
typical
Tyler thread what's the craziest way you
found out someone was cheating on you oh
yeah yeah yeah I think we've asked this
question we've seen Australia it's gone
around it's gone round
some of these ones I've never heard
stuff this before so
craziest way
you found out someone was cheating on
you just off the bat bro the first
comment was your pH balance will tell
you everything you need to know about
your little relationship
oh
oh bro oh my God your pH balance will
tell you everything you need to know
about your little relationship that last
bit is like why man you've already
stabbed me shank in a Twist bro
[__] mad bro right next one I jokingly
guessed his email password and locked
unlocked the Chamber of Secrets
you did it yeah
you're saying what I'm thinking [__]
jokingly guessed his email password well
on the first try of course bro the [__]
what do you mean jokingly yeah was he
there
because if he was he would have smack
challenge with the keyboard oh Rags
that's where the art and what's he got
going on in his emails bro
bro old school that is old school right
he tweeted at the car lot with Bay I was
looking at the Four Walls of my bedroom
oh my God bro that's not even funny
that's just poor planning yeah the time
Management's all over the game all over
the game he'd given up he's given up on
a Sharad
the goal he was with is is bana yeah
yeah she got demoted to cyber 100 she's
probably always been side bay and he was
like I can't even bother to pretend
anymore I want to go outside with the
love of my life I'm not pretending
anymore
don't come to me blame 12. don't come to
me blame you you read what you read what
you read bro don't text me again
algorithm did what he needed to do you
found out shut up shut up
oh
God at that second shop sweetie
um all right oh this one's drape
I worked with the other woman's mum she
saw my husband's picture as my
screensaver and asked how I knew her
daughter's boyfriend
wow
she was probably thinking raw small
world the mom was like wrong well your
brother screensaver yeah that's a lot
screen saver that's what we thinking how
do you know my sister my sister my
daughter's boy my daughter's boyfriend
she was like pardon family
your screensaver how do you know him him
that's my husband should we do a list
it's my husband that's my husband that's
my daughter's mind
listen
listen everything everything everything
will be going wrong that day everything
you've worked so hard for is just gone
bang because he's claiming another girl
met the mom
that's two that's too many lives for one
man yeah he's he's ruined it oh he's
ruined why would you put so much energy
into that cheat yeah yeah that's too
many lives oh Jesus met the mom that's
Brazen Jesus
right
this one's front his airpods his airpods
went off loudly in his ear reading out a
text message saying I miss that dick so
much
foreign
wow in a Siri voice
I miss that dick so much
text message from Sarah reading I miss
that dig so much reply reply
mad mad to reply say yes
he would have been look at his phone
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God that's what you're always
thinking he's texting
stop stop stop stop stop stop everything
yeah bro run run run she's got it she's
got this she's got it he'd be waiting
for a fist in his jaw oh straight away
straight away Jesus Christ that's not
right the X came to the ring doorbell
and talked for two hours this person
wasn't female
Bollywood twist bro wow this person
wasn't female wow a Brother's just
chatting [__] at the ring doormail
drunk and need in need of closure I need
my man back I want my [__] man I know
he's in there bring him out
I want my [__] man back
as
the woman in in the relationship how
would you handle that you're in you're
right yard
your man is in that yard yeah the X-Man
is outside doorbell same scenario just
going off what are you doing he's just
jean shorts ass out jeans shorts that's
fat yes fat
yes yes
oiled
yeah and he just turns around and just
bring him out bring him out I know he
misses this
what are you doing there's nothing I
can't do because it will also top me up
fat if he wants to he's getting in the
yard
fair oh I will just cry and cry and cry
and cry because it's actually dry
because it's something I actually can't
comprehend because as a man if the same
thing happened
with my girl and there's a female at the
door trying to [__] I would just laugh
we're just like I might be a little bit
frustrated I'm like I feel I feel lied
to but I'll be like what the [__] is
this clown show yeah yeah get off my
doorstep yeah before I bust your head
it's embarrassing for you yeah get a
[__] off my doorstep yeah
but a brother
saying I want a dick back
in me
she would be throwing yeah it should be
throwing up and just crying and wouldn't
know what the [__] to do I want that
dick back I don't need that [__] dick
back give him back
that's a bang bang bang bang give him
back no no see I'll be scared the First
Bank you know you know when they bang
the door right and the other side of
your flap exits
you know this weight and the lampshade
is just swinging bang bang bang bang
bang give it back
listen you'd have the thing is you'd
have to call him also it's also one of
them ones where
you would feel like such an idiot
because you've never seen the signs
you've never ever seen the signs and
it's like am I the full yeah yeah like
what where did I go wrong you know what
I mean literally like God why me
oh bro that's a lot that's too much
that's a lot two hours of this that's
harassment that's harassment if you've
never called the feds way before hour
one way before our wonderful give him
back give me that [__] back oh God yeah
she'd be on the floor huh yeah yeah she
can handle that yeah that's not fair
um good Lord all right a few more
scrolling through an x-rated site and
saw him there zoomed in and saw my
picture in the background
this is the marital bed
he's clapping a thing on filming the
marital bro
that's not that's Unforgivable
that's unfiction I would fall out of my
computer chair immediately that is
unforgivable bro on Soldier Boy's
internet
hacks bro
oh my God on the baby's internet
just bang bang bang with the picture in
the Bible
I do like clean up do you diligence son
he didn't care bro he didn't care he
wanted his poem cheeks facts bro he went
cheeks he went money [__] Jesus right
the person he was cheating
the person he was cheating with told me
both times
I took him back just for him to do it a
third time she told me the same day
oh oh my God that's your business that's
your problem bro that's your [__]
business yeah fool me once bro shame on
you for me twice come on man bro
she came home in the morning tired
hugging me and telling me how much she
loves me I knew from then I was back on
the street
that intuition kicked in that Spidey
kicked in I knew from then I was back on
the street she came home tired hugging
me I love I love you I love you man just
knew
straight away oh because he I don't have
a house anymore she's not been like
she's not been this affectionate in
months 100 man why are you so tired that
is morning
I knew I was back on the street that's
jokes this one this one was tweeted by
someone we know really yeah fam Okay saw
him on Deal or No Deal with his
girlfriend telling him to take their 8K
that is jokes bro oh
Audrey
big receipts Audrey take tell him to
take the 8K I I
will pray to God it's a rerun
I'll pray to God this is itv2 bro and it
has to be a rerun pause my sky then and
then yeah that meant that I start
Belling everyone else
lock in because I need the receipts
[__] wow bro
wow bro tell them to take the 8K
[Music]
this one's crazy oh God hit me last one
I found that adsey was posting to be a
bottom boy for transgender women
a bottom boy
a bottom boy bro
boy
that
phrasing that baby
the phrasing because bottom means both
things
a bottom boy
wow ads
advertisements for these cheeks yeah
that oh
like what's
going on in your life to have to do this
oh God knows bro because
it's all well again if you want to
advertise for cheese that's your
business but advertising for cheeks
whilst you've got a partner yeah it's
not it's crazy what do you expect to
happen The Thirst is more important than
this relationship facts bro the first is
more important than the guilt
and if if you really wanted it that bad
what he he wants to get penetrated yeah
he wants to get banged but he's not gay
yeah yeah he wants to get banged by a
woman
but then tell your girl to strap to have
the conversation it was flesh there's no
there's no she doesn't feel there's no
strap it was a feeling he wants to feel
the body it doesn't work
plastic [__] it was he yeah
none of this plastic hippity-dippity
[__] bro I'm on flesh Goodness Me
but um
bro wow I don't even understand next
time any man pissed me off that's the
that's the first part I'm saying oh you
[__] shut up you little bottom boy
you start stuttering bro Boom Boogie
little bomb Boy watch him little bomb
boy
nah
yeah yeah I've bewild your whole life
facts wow boy oh yeah man funny thread
yeah very very very finely cool right
we're gonna finish on trash news please
sir let's go let's go let's go
okay plane turns around mid-fly after
passenger has diarrhea that's his
business alive that's his business
everyone's business get me home because
yeah the flight gots bun
at Delta Airlines flight from Atlanta to
Barcelona has had to had to return to
Atlanta after it's not a short trip
Atlanta to Barcelona it's not short also
what are people doing in Atlanta going
to Barcelona
I'm sorry I don't want to be rude
it's a Barcelona that doesn't add up
you might do it don't have no business
in Barcelona I've never been a ladder
but you've got no business
go to Miami first
[Laughter]
[__] you have no business in Barcelona
you bottom boy [__]
the listeners from ATL are going to
crucify YouTube
[__]
yo
yo you're gonna see quavo in your
request yeah bro you're gonna see man in
your requests bro
[__]
from Andre 3000 is about to end you guys
too you're gonna come for you that's top
three funniest things you've said off
the car oh
boy
wow they're gonna be angry they're going
to be stupid wow they're going to be
angry all right cool yeah go on here we
go flight was two hours into its Journey
when the pilots told the air traffic
controllers they were turning back the
airline confirmed there had been a
medical issue on board and that meant
the plane had to return to Atlanta to be
cleaned the plane landed in Barcelona
eight hours behind schedule clean
cleaned there's a mark
we've got a VN to listen to oh oh okay
oh this is from the pilot oh okay
reporting this is a good black box thing
yeah oh damn okay cool
diary all the way
[Applause]
diary all the way through the airplane
so they want us to come back to Atlanta
they were running Coast to Coast
they were running Coastal coasters
[__] all the way through the
airplane now
wow wow I wow I don't care what
um what's the word I'm looking for I
don't care what seat I'm on yeah like if
the economy toilet's locked I'm dot into
first class yeah I don't care what you
might have telling me man shot all up
and down the runway yeah that's long wow
that's the worst thing that's the worst
thing that's the most embarrassing I'm
locking myself in a toilet and I'm not
coming out until we're back in Atlanta
and everyone's off the plane
that's the worst way to go out yeah it
is like there's not much more
embarrassing you might as well open a
door bro
you might just open a door yeah
I can't see a way out of this two hours
there were two hours in two hours in
that's a u-turn
yeah man said it's a biomedical Hazard
or something yeah biomedical Hazard
someone's just shot all up and down the
plane
that is a hazard that's a huge Hazard
it's the worst thing I'm not cleaning
that I promise you I'm not cleaning that
contagious [__] I'll leave with the rest
of the the whole thing
Jesus Christ horrible man I couldn't be
on that plane I couldn't be on the aisle
seat and feel like a speck of Splash
a splash of diarrhea just touches me
yeah I don't think you can't even
physically cost the brother because he's
just [__] everyone everywhere you
can't get close every Punchy [__] my
Knuckles will pop I'm squeezing my I'm
I'm not gonna pop bro
squeezing my face so tight when I go a
pot
oh god wow wow crazy crazy
damn all right fair play right guys
we're gonna charge that one there yeah I
apologize for food Hut I apologize for
what he said don't send for me I said
for me it's the funniest thing I've
heard I had to do but don't say it was
too perfect it was perfect it was worth
it it was worth it bro wow that was
funny
oh boy [__]
oh I bet anyway guys We're Gonna Leave
You There catch us on Thursday on
patreon.com uh four slash Jason gigs
three pound a month Tempe a day run the
pizza sng love love love
[Music]
foreign